hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google one of the
principles of cartoon animation that we
spoke about recently at a Google i/o
talk called a moving experience is the
idea that motion in our real world is
not linear so if you want a UI to feel
more natural to the user more organic
more like it's a real-world application
then maybe the motion in your
application shouldn't be linearly now we
already offer this by default in all of
the animations in the platform in terms
of time interpolators because you can
set deceleration motion acceleration
motion overshooting we have by default
you accelerate into and out of any
animation so the time aspect is already
handled so that feels a little bit more
natural than simple linear interpolation
however the motion on the screen is not
handled automatically if you want to
move let's say a view from the upper
left side of the screen down to the
lower right side of the screen and you
want it to follow a curve instead of a
straight line it may not be immediately
obvious how to do that so this is why I
wrote an article a while ago on my blog
my blog is at graphics - geek blog
spot.com
the article is called a curved motion in
android so you can go check out that
article
it's basically most of what I'm going to
be showing today so you can go read that
for more information but I wanted to
give a brief glimpse of how you would do
that using the existing animation API is
that we already offer in the platform so
we can take a look at the following demo
very simple we have a boring button on
the upper left side of the screen and
now it's a boring button on the lower
right side of the screen so these are
two different layouts where we determine
where the button needs to be in the two
positions and we basically just toggle
between them but as we toggle between
them we animate the position change
using the approach that I'll go over in
the code starting now okay so in our
click listener we call this method
called move button here this simply sets
the layout parameters to tell the button
to be either at the upper left or lower
right
very straightforward then we add an on
pre-draw listener which is
Niq that I use a lot in animation demos
which basically allows layout to run
from the previous change in this case we
set the layout parameters on the view
layout is going to run and then it's
going to change the position of the
button but before we draw that change on
the screen we're going to figure out
where the button is now we know where it
was before because we track that in
these old left and old top properties up
here and now we can figure out the Delta
between those between the X and the y
values and animate the change now if all
we did was set up an animation to
animate X and animate y very easy to set
up but it's going to give you the linear
motion that simply moves the button
linearly from the upper left to the
lower right and we really wanted the
curved motion instead so we're going to
use some helper classes in here
we're going to use this animator path
class that I've defined that's similar
to but you much simpler than the path
object that we provide in the framework
it also has a query capability that will
return this array of points which is
sort of important for the interpolation
that I needed to do with it so in the
animator path you can basically use one
of three methods to set up your path you
can do a move to a line too and a curve
too so I'm going to tell the path to
move to the old position of the button
and then curve to the new position of
the button and the arguments to the
curve 2 are both the end position as
well as a couple of control points in
the middle and this is basically
defining a cubic Bezier spline between
the two points we have anchor points at
the end and control points in the middle
that determine the motion of that object
along this curve in this case is a
simple curve that's just going to go in
a simple arc down to the lower right and
then back to the upper left we create an
object animator on our objects and we're
going to animate this property called
button look which I've defined a
property setter for which we'll see
below we're going to use this path
evaluator which is a class I defined to
evaluate between these different types
of objects one of the nice things about
the property animation system is sure
you can animate floats and ends but
sometimes you have a more complex data
structure like a rect or a point or in
this case the
path objects these path points along the
curve then how would you interpolate
along those well the system doesn't know
how to but you can tell it how to by
providing one of these type evaluators
to get a callback on every frame and
then you simply do the interpolation for
the system and pass back the appropriate
values and then finally for the points
that are going to animate between we do
a query into our animator path and
that's going to return this array of
points that define the animation we set
an interpolator on this thing and we
start and we're all good to go so we can
take a look at the bottom we have this
property setter that would be defined
called set button Lok this is going to
get this object called path point which
is a data structure that holds the
information and then we simply set the
translation X and translation Y property
of the view according to what was in
that path point object we can take a
look at the path points this is simply a
data structure that says what kind of
point is this it's a move or a line or a
curve and then has information about
those points internally the animator
path that we saw before allows you to
build up this path of successive points
and then query the points once you're
done so we can actually set up the
animation on it and then finally we have
the type evaluator and the one that we
defined is called path eval your
evaluator and it just uses this
straightforward calculation so it looks
like a lot of garbage going on in here
this is actually a really simple
calculation it's a standard spline
calculation so given a value T the time
in this animation we can calculate the x
and y values on the curve one caveat
that I mentioned in the article as well
is this is not necessarily the motion
all along the curve that you want what
you really want is in general to take
the T value of how far along the curve
is and use that to extract your x and y
values that requires a little bit more
code I didn't want to get into it in
this simple example the effect that
you'd get by using this simplistic
approach here is on a hairpin turns
you'd go a lot faster so you really want
to spread out that motion evenly along
the curve kind of a detail maybe it'll
matter in some of your curves so you
should know about it but if you want a
simple approach here's one
so curved motion in general if you're
moving stuff on the screen that's not
just going in one axis consider moving
it in a curve to get
the user more of a natural and organic
feeling for your application make them
feel like they're actually interacting
with something in the real world instead
of just some user interface on a boring
screen thanks